لكل بلد ثقفته ونظرته الخاصه للبقشيش ورغم
ان الاختلافات طفيفه الا انها قد تشكل
مساله حساسه في اسيا يجب عليك في البدايه
تحديد ما اذا كان يجب عليك تقديم البقشيش
على الاطلاق اما في اوروبا اعطاء البقشيش
لا يعد شائعا في اسبانيا وفي ايطاليا
عموما رسوم الخدمه عاده ما تضاف الى
فواتير الفنادق والمطاعم وفي بريطانيا
يعتبر البقشيش معتادا في حال كنت راضيا عن
الخدمه وفي فرنسا الاكراميه ليست الزاميه
لكنها بمثابه مفاجاه ساره في امريكا اي
خدمه تقريبا تعد قابله للبقشيش وفي اجزاء
كثيره من الولايات المتحده اصبحت نسبه 20%
اكراميه مالوفه الى حد ما اما كندا فتقع
ما بين اوروبا والولايات المتحده من حيث
ثقافه البقشيش يعني دفع بقشيش بنسبه 15%
للخدمه الجيده في المطاعم وفي المكسيك
الاكراميه ليست الزاميه لكنها متوقعه
على العموم سال الناس في السعوديه والعراق
برايك ما هي قيمه الاكراميه التي يجب
دفعها نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
هو اصلا المفروض ما يكون في اكراميه لان
هذا عمله واجبه يسوي الشهاده ياخذ عليه
راتب فما في كل واحد يسوي عمل انا ادفع
الفلوس وادفع الاكراميه فاعتقد اذا انا
مضطر ادفع اكراميه ما تعدل 5% 10% بالكثير
يعني في احيانا قليله ممكن ما يعطيك رميها
عشره
مقرون بامرين الخدمه قديش كويسه وقديش
الفاتوره كبيره يمكن عشره او 15% من قيمه
الفاتوره مثلا بحدود العشره ريال الى
العشرين على حسب الخدمه المقدمه
هي تحدد الاكراميه يعني بحيث اذا كانت
برضو حتى الخدمه سيئه مستحيل بتاخذ
اكراميه عليها والله انا ما لها سقف محدد
على حسب الاستطاعه في حينه يعني انا مع
الاكراميه
اذا سواء اوتيل او مطعم
حلوه يعني
وتشجع العامل او الموظف على انه يعطي
زياده
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات